we have to talk about the big news that
dropped yesterday
you filed for divorce from princess
first of all how are you feeling
what are your thoughts today i haven't
gotten a lot of sleep lately so
i literally kind of just went to sleep
i'm like what a couple hours ago and
then i woke up and i'm like man there's
a lot of people here everybody's
set it's like you could see the whole
set we like doing five things at once
so my mind is still busy i haven't
really had a chance to kind of sit back
and think about it you know we going
through the whole legal thing so i can't
really say too much
until everything is all said and done
but um you know
i love her i love my babies you know
it's just personal but
she knows how i feel about her i just
think that i want to make sure everybody
is happy that
everybody enjoys life if this can help
her smile more
and enjoy who she is and and enjoy her
life
then you know sometimes it's the best
thing to do so
what happens was it more so to set her
free
because you know she filed for divorce
you know this of course it's your life
she filed for divorce from you in may
but then dismissed the fouling in july
so now you're fouling you know what was
your motive or your intention behind
making this move
it was just how i felt at the time i i
didn't really i didn't really talk to
nobody about it
because it was you know i feel like when
you talk you get too many opinions
and you you know you ask too many people
about something you personally feel and
at the end of the day when they leave
you still feel the same way you know
it's like what should i do and then
whatever opinion they give you
when they leave you're still stuck by
yourself you know
so i just went to god and um you know
it's still so early
um i really don't know what's going to
happen
how it happens i just want to make sure
that my babies and my princess is
in a great place mentally and that they
can enjoy life and especially my wife
you know if there's somebody better out
there
that she wants to be with then you know
i have to respect that as well but
i don't know you know i really don't
know i haven't really practiced this
this question either it's just i just
can't say too much
but i love you princess that's what i
can say
well i appreciate you opening up about
this because i know it
is still so fresh and so personal but
the reason why i really wanted to have
this conversation is because so many
people can learn
from you you know exactly what you just
said i think is a gem for a lot of
people that could potentially be
watching this
do you think all hope is lost when it
comes to this relationship or are you
keeping it open and whatever
it's meant to be will be i think if you
like a if you're
a guy and you know you you had
you know you played your part in
whatever happened i think
you have to be a man and say i'm sorry
and admit to
hurting somebody that you love and
genuinely be sorry about it
the outcome of that you know i mean just
because you're sorry doesn't mean that
it's okay you know just because you're
sorry doesn't mean that
everything's gonna be back to how it was
and so
that's not what this song is it's just
saying that listen
i'm sorry if you're sorry
that's cool but you don't have to be
honest i'm sorry
and this is why i'm sorry um
even if you know we don't make it we
still have to be with each other a lot
because we
had a baby so we're together for life
happiness is important
i think our sacrifice i'll sacrifice all
my happiness for my kids
and so um with that said
we'll just we'll just have to wait and
see you know but i want to make sure
that they're
in a good space and that she's in a
great space you know throughout this
journey as parents as well it's
important for us to be great parents
first in my opinion yeah then let
relationship flow after
very good point well you have melody and
epic you're two beautiful babies with
princess
have you thought about you know how you
will explain everything that has
happened in the public eye to them in
the future
nah no
yeah ray you're making me a little
emotional
i know this is hard for you um and
definitely i know it's hard for princess
too so once again
i can't say this enough i appreciate you
opening up about it
um of course people online don't know
the ins and outs of your relationships
so they have opinions
but how do you deal with handling all of
this so publicly
you know how what do you what are you
what do you go home and think about
i haven't been home i've been living
here i just been working you know
uh it's like
i've been just i haven't looked at like
the internet or nothing like when
something's going on like this i don't
really dwell
like look at what's happening i just
kind of channel
out so we just blocked everything out
and just trying to stay focused on the
work
what do you think the biggest lesson is
that you've learned through this time
i haven't yet well i hear some lessons
you know
princess and your kids happiness of
course comes first before your joy and i
think
that's a big sacrifice you know so
that's a lesson but
just make sure you take some time to
reflect and digest it all and don't just
use work
to suppress it you know i try
you know it's like like you can't say
too much because
you know actions speak louder than words
you know so
um i could say a bunch of stuff but it's
all about how you
you know treat people how you act how
you uh
respect people and how they respect you
as well you know respect is real
important
in a relationship and so i want to keep
that in the forefront
and um and you know just just give it to
god you know
well those are some powerful lessons
that you just said right there i think
they're very valuable you two have a few
things in the works together
one of them is to show the conversation
how do you plan to move forward
when it comes to working together again
we still want to build our empire
you know as as for our kids
and um and princess is a really good
executive producer
um she really goes out and either
make sure we have the right talent or if
there's issues
um inside of the scenes you know she'll
get on the phone and
make everything go away and make
everything right so
from the producer side i think she has a
long career ahead of her as an executive
producer
and um and you know i'm near all the way
through with whatever
whatever projects we work on now
they do have a long life so i will be
able to you know sit
and have some time with her you know
producing the shows
once again i appreciate you open opening
up and i send
you both and your beautiful babies just
good vibes and love you know
that you see this through with strength
and everything works out for the best of
all of you
thank you all right your new single hurt
you dropped
this friday can you tell us a little bit
about the story behind this song how did
it come to be
this song came about not too long ago
um we we've been working on a lot of
different projects
um from tech to television but sometimes
you just you know after you finish work
after you finish a long day i worked to
come back to the studio
but i practically lived here you know i
just started to put some of my emotions
into the music and
one of my guys peso already had to beat
up and he had kind of had the concept
and he was going through something and i
was going through something
and um and then the song just came about
and usually like we had another plan to
release another record but i said before
we even get to any record
i feel like this is a this is a letter
like a love letter that i got to get off
my chest
i love letter to princess right
i'm just a love letter you know i mean
when you when you personalize music
from the heart you make that connection
but you are writing the song
and connecting the song with everybody
and what everybody is going through as
well so
um you know it's my perspective but when
you listen to it
i mean there's so many different ways
you can take the record and roll with it
so you know
it's called hurt you it's out it's right
this friday
so fingers crossed man i hope y'all like
it yeah and the music video
you were shedding real tears i mean this
song
obviously brings up a lot of raw emotion
for you
yeah it does um i don't think we're
gonna release that video
we might i look but you know it's tough
sometimes you know what i mean but again
we gotta just keep stay focused
keep our heads on straight and you know
just try to just try to you know take it
one day at a time
what's the status of radiation x are we
still going to get that this fall
it's coming out september 25th okay
and that's what i've been working on for
the past like couple months is just
trying to make sure this
one wish anniversary project and um and
all the songs that we all been doing
really see the light the right way
because um a few times just when i'm
doing technology
sometimes my my music focus is off and
so i haven't really been
putting my 100 into the music but this
time
we're gonna take a big shot at it yeah
you have to do it for one wish because i
still
can recite almost every lyric to that
song 15 years later
hey that's and that's a blessing and for
me and the team
i mean we we're independent artists like
we're
i'm a serious independent artist meaning
you know i have a team and we actually
have to invest
our own capital into this and and see a
profit
as opposed to having an imprint deal so
for you to say that is a blessing and
thank you thank
you to everybody that supported one wish
we're coming back with a new version
and a whole new radiation x album
[Music]
revised